[Música]
cuántas amigas tienen en facebook
tengo unas mil aproximadamente gente que
conozco poco o mucho de distintos lados
ahora hagamos un ejercicio
quiero que piensen en tres de ellas
solamente tres
ya tienen los nombres
si esa fuera una selección
representativa a nivel nacional dos de
sus tres amigas
serían víctimas de violencia de pareja
dos de tres
en efecto según datos del ine y en el
perú dos de cada tres mujeres ha sido
víctima de violencia física psicológica
o sexual de parte de su pareja estos
datos provienen de la endes que es una
encuesta grande la encuesta nacional de
demografía y salud familiar que cada año
encuesta 35.000 hogares
somos un país violento incluso en una
región violenta como américa latina'
ocupamos el top 3 de países con mayor
violencia de género
no es un sitio para sentirnos orgullosos
este mes que cuando estamos ante un
problema grande como el de la violencia
de género
que no sabemos resolver solemos
simplificar este problema y entonces
sacamos conjeturas rápidas del mismo y
al hacerlo usamos un sentido común que
está lleno de estereotipos
estereotipos que no siempre sabemos o
podemos cuestionar
y entonces con esas conjeturas rápidas
creamos mitos como uno por ejemplo que
la violencia contra las mujeres se
concentre las mujeres de pocos recursos
o dos que es fácil identificar un
agresor porque la violencia aparece
rápido en la relación
pero esto es un mito verdad
veamos que dicen los datos
en este primer gráfico lo que nosotros
representamos en la población dividida
en cinco grupos son quintiles que es una
medida que se utiliza mucho en las
ciencias sociales están ordenados estos
grupos en función del nivel
socioeconómico
y acá lo que vemos rápidamente es que el
33 por ciento de mujeres en el quintil
de menos recursos ha sido víctima de
violencia física en el último año en el
quintil de más recursos el 27 por ciento
lo ha sido la diferencia entre dos
grupos no es grande es poca entonces
rápidamente desmentimos este mito que
hemos tejido la violencia no se
concentra exclusivamente las mujeres de
bajos recursos atraviesa todas las
clases sociales
y que en este segundo mito este que nos
dice que fácil identificar un agresor
porque agrede rápido ni bien inicia la
relación acá nuevamente nos topamos con
una realidad que hemos simplificado
los datos muestran un patrón cuando
vemos esta estadística que nos resume
cuando apareció la primera agresión
física los datos muestran un patrón yo
lo llamo la regla del 25
en un 25 por ciento de mujeres la
primera agresión aparece en el primer
año rápido eso sí en un segundo 25%
aparece en el segundo año
en un tercer 25% aparece entre el tercer
y el cuarto año
en el último 25% aparece en el quinto
año después o mucho después incluso
luego de más de diez años
los que estos datos nos muestran el que
no es fácil identificar un agresor la
violencia puede aparecer mucho después
puede demorarse en aparecer
entonces esto lo que estos primeros
datos nos muestran
es una realidad muy compleja diversa no
hay un único tipo de perfil de víctima
hay distintos perfiles de víctimas
y entonces rápidamente nos damos cuenta
que no son parecidas a las víctimas y
que hay muchas diferencias y que por
tanto nosotros podemos encontrar
diferencias porque la violencia es más
alta entre las mujeres que tienen empleo
por ejemplo
la violencia es alta pero diferente
entre las mujeres que tienen español
quechua o aymara como lengua materna
lo que ha pasado entonces es que las
tendemos a simplificar y a juntar a
todas cuando en realidad son
heterogéneas
por eso es que es mejor hablar de
violencia contra las mujeres en plural
en lugar de hablar de violencia contra
la mujer en singular porque cuando
usamos este singular lo que pasa es que
la simplificamos y las estereotipamos al
estereotipo de la víctima perfecta
tímida e introvertida sin mayor poder
y los datos muestran que la realidad no
es así dejemos de invisibilizar a la
pluralidad de las mujeres
pero saben a quién es más
invisibilizados a ellos a los hombres
la violencia es un problema que está muy
extendido y el lugar más peligroso para
las mujeres es paradójicamente donde
vive en su hogar y los hombres su pareja
son generalmente los agresores el gran
problema no son ellas son ellos
pero cuando hablamos de violencia de
género
generalmente a ellos no los ponemos en
el primer plano
para ilustrar esto yo busqué en google
algo que directamente pudiera
identificar a los agresores de mujeres y
puse agresor de mujer y miren las
imágenes que salieron mujeres por todos
lados hay mujeres incluso con rostros
identificables pero los hombres están
difuminados no aparece y esto que es muy
gráfico en google también es un reflejo
de lo que pasa en nuestras cabezas
hemos difuminado a los hombres del
problema y hemos puesto énfasis en las
víctimas pero al hacer este énfasis les
hemos dado también la carga del problema
y la carga de la solución mientras que
los hombres siguen difuminados
por eso es que es muy común encontrar
que muchas imágenes de publicidad de
violencia contra las mujeres recurran a
esta figura casi universal una mujer
levantando la mano y diciendo para stop
- qué pasa ahí
nuevamente les hemos dado la carga a las
mujeres mientras que los hombres están
difuminados
difuminar los de las imágenes es solo un
reflejo de cómo hemos difuminado a los
hombres del problema y también por tanto
como los hemos difuminado de las
soluciones
al no entender a los agresores como los
vamos a incorporar por tanto no tiene
mucho sentido porque hay muchas
preguntas sin respuesta quiénes son
estos agresores porque agrede les pegan
a todo el mundo son enfermos mentales
el problema de tener estas preguntas sin
respuesta es que nos llevan a soluciones
sin mucho contenido el problema de tener
estas preguntas sin respuesta es que las
cubrimos nuevamente con estereotipos
para tratar de conocer al agresor
y entonces creamos esta imagen perfecta
del agresor estereotipada la antropóloga
norma fowler nos señala que el
estereotipo que hemos construido como
sociedad de agresor es este impositivos
siempre dispuestos a agredir enfermos
mentales
entonces tendemos a alejarlos de la
sociedad y como no los conocemos
adecuadamente entonces rápidamente
buscamos hacer conjeturas rápidas sobre
quiénes son y les quitamos la
responsabilidad porque en cierta forma
nos conviene a los hombres los
convertimos en sujetos excepcionales los
estereotipamos al máximo hasta
convertirlos en marginales en el
imaginario popular por eso es que los
ciudadanos enfermos mentales
y la juventud también lo piensa en una
encuesta del 2017 de la universidad san
martín de porres yo se encuestaron a
cuatro mil universitarios a nivel
nacional tanto universidades públicas
como privadas y nos preguntaron algo
bien simple y directo ustedes piensan
que los agresores de mujeres son
enfermos mentales el 85 por ciento dijo
que sí que si piensa que los
y eso sucede en opiniones que vemos
todos los días por ejemplo en redes
sociales si nos detenemos a leer los
comentarios a una noticia sobre una
agresión
vamos a ver comentarios que dicen
rápidamente
es agresor es un psicópata es un
monstruo es un enfermo mental
esta encuesta que yo les comentaba tenía
preguntas adicionales
y específicamente le preguntaron a estos
jóvenes si es que ellos a greg dirían a
su pareja en alguna situación
los resultados muestran un giro muy
chocante muy preocupante
un
34% de ellos respondió que le pegaría
cuando ella tenga la culpa
un 45% casi la mitad respondió que le
pegaría levemente sin lastimarla un 46%
uno de cada dos respondería que le
pegaría por alguna razón
un
57% seis de cada diez le pegaría porque
él pierde el control
primer la gravedad de esto
estamos en una sociedad donde muchos
jóvenes no todos pero muchos declaran
abiertamente que le pegarían a su pareja
y que serían tal como esos enfermos
mentales que tildaron minutos antes en
encuesta
estamos en una sociedad en la cual la
violencia contra las mujeres está
largamente avalada y normalizada
mientras que de otro lado rápidamente
estereotipamos a los agresores y los
tildamos e marginales es una tremenda
contradicción pero quizás valga la pena
preguntarnos si los agresores de mujeres
son realmente enfermos mentales
para tratar de responder esto nos
metimos a la cárcel y entrevistamos a
344 reos de dos cárceles en el país
lurigancho y castro castro eran reos
condenados son procesados por
feminicidio tentativa y feminicidio
violación sexual etcétera
y hallamos que los estereotipos de la
sociedad no eran los correctos
los agresores no eran iguales eran
distintos y armamos una tipología de
agresores los clasificamos en tres tipos
el primer tipo es pedrito
pedrito representa el
73% de nuestra muestra solo agreguen a
su pareja y lo hacen con una baja
intensidad porque agreguen con
frecuencia y severidad bajas
ninguno tenía trastornos de personalidad
que es como deberíamos llamar
correctamente a lo que más llamamos
enfermedad mental no calza con nuestro
estereotipo
y se limitan a agredir al ámbito
familiar y todas estas razones hacen que
sean sujetos que pasan desapercibidos
entonces es el típico caso pedrito del
colega de trabajo que nos enteramos que
agredió a su pareja y nos hace soltar un
no puedo creer que lo hacía cuando nos
enteramos del hecho
o como aquel chico que conocí en el
aeropuerto el año pasado y que resultó
ser el amigo de un agresor de un caso
bastante mediático y este chico me dijo
que raro yo nunca lo he visto agredir a
su nueva pareja
el segundo tipo de agresor es un perito
pero intensidad mucho más alta
representa un porcentaje menor en la
muestra 23% agrede solo a su pareja pero
lo hace con una intensidad muy fuerte
con frecuencia y severidad alta tanto
psicológica física como sexualmente
pero tampoco casi ninguno tenía
trastornos de personalidad
el tercer tipo es el que nosotros
pensamos que es la regla pero en
realidad es la excepción
solamente 4 de cada 100 de los que
entrevistamos entraron a este tercer
tipo solamente ellos
tenían trastornos de personalidad
específicamente antisocial y that
borderline y dependencia pero bien
nuevamente son la excepción
no son la regla
y además acá es importante mencionar que
tiene un trastorno de personalidad no me
convierte necesariamente en un agresor
yo les acabo de comentar que los
agresores son diversos son distintos
pero saben que comparten
pensamiento machista
nosotros en las entrevistas
identificamos que un 76 por ciento de
los agresores cree que si las mujeres
supieran podrían prevenir futuros
episodios de violencia
un 81 por ciento de los agresores
piensan que los agresores como ellos
tienen graves problemas psicológicos y
que a menudo no saben lo que hacen
un
66% considera que los que agreden a sus
parejas se sienten avergonzados y
culpables por ello
veamos el mensaje de fondo los hombres
nuevamente se difuminan del escenario no
saben lo que hacen mientras que las
mujeres cargan con el problema si
supieran los dejar ir
es el pensamiento machista
pero que las feministas nos han estado
diciendo por décadas y que como sociedad
no lo hemos tomado del todo en serio
leerlo ahora desde los agresores es
distinto tiene un efecto diferente
y lo más preocupante y kaká no es un
tema de solo los agresores lo
preocupante es que esta forma de pensar
machista está insertada en los
estereotipos que comparte compartimos
todavía como sociedad
estamos frente a un problema grave y
tenemos que hacernos cargo pero para
hacernos cargo tenemos que tener una
mirada completa del problema y no a
invisibilizar a los hombres pero no se
trata de abrazarnos con los agresores
llorar y perdonarnos por ahí no va la
cosa se trata de mirarnos a los hombres
como parte directa y solidaria del
problema y por tanto también como parte
de la solución
para hacerlo les dejo cuatro ideas
cambiar la forma y el fondo de las
campañas de comunicación contra la
violencia hacia las mujeres tienen que
estar focalizadas pero inteligentemente
en los hombres las ciencias del
comportamiento son bienvenidas dos
tenemos que reenfocar a los programas de
empoderamiento de las mujeres para
trabajar también con sus parejas la
evidencia dice que cuando esto no se
hace estos programas pueden incluso
aumentar la violencia
3 tenemos que trabajar con los niños y
las niñas y los adolescentes pero hoy es
crucial y urgente trabajar con los
adolescentes por dos razones la
evidencia dice nuevamente que trabajar
con ellos tiene resultados de corto
plazo para reducir la violencia y que
además son dos sostenibles en el tiempo
recuerdan las respuestas de esta buena
parte de jóvenes universitarios
tenemos que evitarlo
último punto
en las reuniones familiares
tenemos que centrar nuestra energía en
la mesa de los jóvenes no abandonemos la
de los adultos pero tenemos que
conversar dialogar y discutir con la
mesa de los jóvenes
que este tema no deje de importarnos ni
hoy ni mañana
veamos el problema de violencia de
género en su real dimensión y sin
invisibilizar a las partes este no es un
problema exclusivo de las mujeres
porque la mayoría de las agresiones
viene de las manos de los hombres y de
la indiferencia del resto de hombres que
no son agresores
es hora de que como hombres asumamos
nuestra responsabilidad directa o
solidaria si somos parte del problema es
nuestra responsabilidad ser parte de
estas soluciones también hagámonos cargo
gracias
[Música]